good afternoon police in Thailand say
that a soldier is still on the run
that's after shooting dead at least 17
people and injuring at 21 more well the
shootings happened in the city of nakhon
ratchasima that's around a hundred and
fifty miles to the northeast of Bangkok
where we can speak now to our Southeast
Asia correspondent chef Warren Robbins
she's on her way to the scene we've got
her on the phone line now
Siobhan we are getting reports that
there are dozens of people fleeing from
terminal 21 shopping mall where it's
thought that the gunman this soldier is
still holed up and officials are saying
that the death toll of at least 17 that
could still rise yes it's a really
confused picture at the moment partly
because it's still non-folding
investigation as you say this gunman is
still believed to be on the loose but
also because local media have been asked
not to report live from the scene at the
moment because gunman who is believed to
be inside that terminal 21 shopping
center may be watching those feeds and
getting indications of where the police
and Special Forces are to give you some
more information about what unfolded
were they serve on sorry to interrupt
you we're just getting an update that
apparently police and military have
stormed into that terminal 21 shopping
center there helped hundreds of people
to escape so we don't yet know about the
outcome for the gunman or whether indeed
he is still on the loose but what we do
understand is that police and military
personnel are on the site by that
shopping center yes that's right and we
already knew from an update given to Sky
News by the police that specialist
commandos had been flown to the scene by
a helicopter
from Bangkok and that they had been
helping local police so we knew that
they were planning something when you
were looking at live feeds lots of the
police activity was deliberately being
blocked by vehicles so that the gunman
as I said wasn't being tipped off that
gunman has been names of jack upon Samar
he's a soldier
and police told us earlier today that
this started they got a call around half
past three to reports of a senior
officer being shot and an elderly lady
it's also understood that jacket pan
tomate shot another military official at
an armory where he reportedly stole
weapons he then drove from that barrack
into the city of nakhon ratchasima
towards that terminal 21 shopping center
and then video from that scene appears
to show getting out of the car gunshots
can be heard and reports there that
people were shot as he arrived
unconfirmed reports one of those kills
of the taxi driver also as they say
unconfirmed reports another was a
motorbike taxi rider but really
distressing pictures coming out at the
scene there and during their shooting
spree he appeared to be doing live
Facebook updates for a while so on one
update he posted should I surrender also
pictures of guns on his face but but
that site has now been suspended by
Facebook as you said this is still a
very much unfolding seen those reports
you're betting that police have stormed
the building we don't still know where
he are here reports again from local
media that there were snipers in the
area helping the authorities as well and
the public health minister in the last
few hours had also called for blood
donations to the city to help those who
have been shot but we do know that there
were reports it was holding a number of
hostages so of course we would be hoping
that the news that comes out over the
next minutes and hours will be that they
have all escaped safely but mass
shootings in Thailand are very very rare
we know that this person had posted
about previous shootings on his Facebook
site but when he was hiding it was
believed in that shopping center police
had told other people in the center to
hide and to turn off their or turn their
smartphones on to silence so it's hoped
that many people have managed to escape
that I think we're going to find more
about this it sounds like the police
have moved in now that you should find
another update it
very very shortly